représentée par Kevin Guedj
je demande en ville le
9/03/2018 que tu n'auras aucune pensée
sexuelle ni aucune envie de
te voir et de te toucher par aucune
autre femme que moi
alors bonsoir
alors c'est pas car là
les journalistes people
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette affaire
parce qu'on comprend plus rien Carla
Moreau est-elle victime ou coupable
je pourrais pas dire si elle est victime
ou coupable ce que je peux dire en tout
cas c'est que vous vous souvenez il y a
deux ans cette cette histoire elle date
quand même il y a plusieurs années mais
il y a deux ans elle était même venue
sur votre sur votre plateau parce qu'il
y avait des vidéos et des audios qui
étaient sortis où on pouvait voir et
entendre écarla et sa voyante faire des
espèces
d'incantation pour pour demander du mal
à ses collègues famille de l'émission
phare les Marseillais voilà ça c'est
pour recontextualiser donc c'était il y
a deux ans elle était venue ici où elle
disait que effectivement c'était une
histoire de chantage que la voyante lui
demandait beaucoup d'argent pour ne pas
divulguer ces audio et ses vidéos d'elle
sauf que tout récemment là il y a
quelques jours des nouvelles vidéos sont
effectivement sorties vous l'avez dit
Cyril une espèce de bougie enfin on la
voit dans la vidéo face à une bougie en
forme de de pénis
[Rires]
faut l'allumer
en tout cas en tout cas ça a pas ça a
pas ce qu'elle demande déjà avant de
vous dire si ça a marché ou pas parce
qu'elle demande dans cette vidéo c'est
que son copain de l'époque son mari même
Kevin lui soit fidèle qu'il ne voit
aucune autre femme quelle qu'il comment
je peux dire ça sans choquer les gens
toujours les mots
Jean-Marie quand un homme est content de
voir une femme
ce genre de choses qui lui arrive autre
que pour elle voilà donc on l'entend
bien dans ces dans ces vidéos là il y a
d'autres vidéos un petit peu plus
choquantes et effectivement aussi qui
sont qui sont sortis et là ça remet un
petit peu en cause tout ce qui a pu dire
il y a deux ans à savoir que bah qu'on
lui faisait du chantage parce que là
dans la vidéo on voit clairement qu'elle
n'est pas sous euh
c'est pas du tout une blague non c'est
pas de vue et il se dirait même qu'il y
a d'autres vidéos qui vont sortir où
elle demanderait où elle va enterrer des
ses propres sous-vêtements ainsi que
souvent les sous-vêtements de son mari
Kevin voilà pour qui lui soit fidèle et
qu'il est une attirance ouais ouais
enterrer
ses sous-vêtements aussi pour qu'il n'y
ait plus jamais
aujourd'hui alors il y a une enquête qui
est ouverte il y a des hommes armés qui
seraient entrés au domicile de Carla
Moreau est-ce que c'est vrai c'est selon
Le Parisien il y a 8 hommes armés
effectivement qui serait rentrés dans
son domicile pendant son absence il y a
des vidéos de surveillance dans son dans
son appartement donc ce qui fait que
aujourd'hui on est capable de dire qu'il
y avait 8 hommes armés je sais pas s'il
y a s'il y a un lien de cause à effet
entre cette cette ces dernières vidéos
qui sont sorties et ces hommes qui
seraient rentrés chez elle ce qu'on sait
aussi dans l'article du Parisien c'est
que ces vidéos seraient sorties parce
que
Carla Moreau ça fait quelques temps
qu'elle paierait qu'elle paierait un
blogueur et la voyante pour ne pas
divulguer ces fameuses vidéos qui sont
sorties sauf qu'apparemment depuis
quelques mois elle ne payait plus
elle nous n'aurait plus son contrat
parce que c'était d'après le blogueur
Nabil qui a sorti ses vidéos là c'était
un contrat fait par les avocats de Carla
Moreau et du blogueur et de la voyante
donc c'est fait ça c'est contesté parce
que d'un côté on parle de raquette et de
l'autre côté on dit ça exactement en
tout cas en tout cas d'après eux c'est
un contrat qui a été fait avec les
avocats des des deux parties des trois
parties même et dans lequel on apprend
que Carla Moreau devait verser tous les
mots tous les mois 12000 euros à la
voyante et 20000 euros
annabil ouais pendant 20 mois et
interdiction de parler de cette affaire
pendant 25 ans 25 ans ça c'est selon le
parcours
même de cette vidéo et de ses vidéos
elle pose question parce que c'est une
pièce pour exercer du chantage ça vous
êtes pas obligé de faire de la voyance
et d'être filmé et la voyante qui
s'appelle Danaé donc qui a été très
médiatisée avec cette affaire elle est
devenue connue elle s'est construite une
communauté de cent mille personnes sur
Instagram elle fait encore la promotion
de ce qu'elle fait et je suis allé voir
sur son site elle promet par exemple de
récupérer son ex satisfait ou remboursé
contre plusieurs milliers d'euros en
seulement trois jours donc elle s'est
servi aussi de ça pour faire
c'est toujours autour de récupération
ce cas de Carla et qui était très
attaché à son ex qui allait plus avec
lui aujourd'hui dans les audios et les
vidéos qui sont sortis on entend
vraiment pour pour moi en tout cas des
choses qui sont quand même assez graves
où elle demande quand même à ce qu'une
personne
se suicide carrément en tout cas qu'on
la pousse au suicide que cette personne
devienne folle donc c'est pas que
je voudrais que mon ex enfin mon ex
revienne ou que mon amour reste avec moi
c'est pas c'est pas que ça pour moi ça
va au-delà de ça parce que
voilà demandez à ce que quelqu'un se
pousse se suicide
alors le drame c'est que d'autres faits
comme ça existent dans le domaine de la
téléréalité c'est à dire que il y a
beaucoup de
jeunes femmes notamment qui ont été
consultés une ou des voyantes et qui ont
fait des vidéos c'est voyante pour
garder une pièce à conviction ensuite
pour les faire chanter donc c'est une
affaire qui est exemplaire mais c'est
une pratique assez courante hélas dans
le domaine de la téléréalité et là c'est
symptomatique parce que Carla Moreau
elle avait de très haut revenus et puis
à un moment elle a gagné moins elle ne
pouvait plus payer donc elle a voulu
dénoncer et c'est pour ça que le parquet
ouvre une enquête parce que le parquet
soupçonne que ce contrat qui était fait
sous seing et ça on a le droit soit en
fait effectivement pour masquer
extorsion de fond et chantage donc
l'affaire est grave parce que si à
travers des vidéos vous menacé d'autres
gens là ça prend une toute autre
tournure parce qu'on peut s'interroger
quand même sur le la voyante qui
enregistre à son insu sa cliente en fait
ce qu'elle dit la voyante que c'était
pour s'en servir plus tard en fait ce
qu'elle dit la voyante c'est que elle
elle fait aussi des consultations à
distance donc quand les personnes ne
sont pas en face d'elle et ben elles se
filment pour montrer qu'elle fait bien
les demandes qu'on lui fait sauf que là
aussi bah Carla elle je on sait pas
aujourd'hui on peut pas dire si c'est
elle qui se filme volontairement ou si
elle est filmée par la voyante mais j'ai
la souligné j'ai la signe à souligné
pardon un point important c'est que
aujourd'hui on le sait c'est pas un
secret les placements de produits ne
marchent plus comme avant les revenus
que Carla pouvait gagner avant on
pouvait parler de centaines de milliers
d'euros par mois
les centaines de milliers les centaines
de milliers d'euros qu'elle gagnait il y
a quelques années aujourd'hui c'est plus
du tout le cas
et entre son train de vie et payer et
honorer son contrat c'est impossible
il faut rappeler quand même que la
dernière la voyante elle a été condamnée
à 5 mois de prison 5 mois de prison avec
sursis et 100000 euros d'amende voilà
déjà et le préjudice 100 000 euros a été
confisqué sur son numéro
et car la Moro a dit aux enquêteurs
qu'elle donnait 80% de ses revenus à la
voyante qu'elle consulte depuis le début
de sa carrière
n'est pas là pour juger les croyances
des gens moi effectivement à titre
personnel je trouve que c'est évidemment
un peu grotesque et horrible mais moi
pour moi c'est une dérive sectaire c'est
à dire qu'elle est sous emprise elle est
complètement sous emprise elle ne sait
plus ce qu'elle fait ni de son argent ni
de ses de ses sentiments comme ça et en
fait c'est vraiment très très grave en
fait même si ce que vous dites c'est
qu'elle dit des choses un peu choquantes
sur les vidéos ou des en fait c'est
quelqu'un qui est sous emprise et il y a
quelqu'un qui l'a mis gratin dessus et
comme quand dans les sectes on vous dit
de faire n'importe quoi même de vous
suicider parfois mais elle est comme ça
pour moi car tous les premières les
premières sur les premières vidéos
effectivement ce qu'elle voulait c'était
être la star du programme donc à la
limite je vous regarde plus parce qu'en
fait
elle voulait être la star du programme
ça la limite bon il y a pas de mal
envers envers des tiens je vous vois
encore Cyril
il y a pas de mal à autrui ça ça peut
aller débourser quelques euros pour pour
demander à être une femme ça peut passer
mais quand on demande à faire du à faire
du mal quand on veut
on en vient à faire du mal à ça en
famille à ses propres amis aux gens qui
nous à l'environnement c'est-à-dire
qu'on est plus maître justement de mais
moi je vais aller un petit peu plus loin
parce que si elle voulait avoir
le regardes pas pour l'arrêter
je sais pas comment vous faites
nous non plus non mais à la limite enfin
moi je vais je vais pointer le doigt sur
autre sur autre chose c'est que si elle
a voulu être
si elle a voulu être la star si elle
c'est aussi peut-être parce qu'on l'a
poussé indirectement dans les programmes
aussi c'est à dire qu'on sait que si
dans un programme tu n'es pas tu n'es
pas une star tu ne fréquentes pas des
hommes voilà et ben on t'éjecte des
programmes donc
bonsoir excusez-moi de vous déranger
si tu sers à rien sur un programme si tu
donnes pas voilà ce qui fonctionne c'est
à dire un peu les couples les histoires
roman c'est tout oui tu te taises après
il y en a quand même qui arrive à rester
avec juste leur personnalité comme toi
ah oui oui
dans ton environnement il y a quoi il y
avait des voyants mais jamais de la vie
moi c'est vraiment un truc que je trouve
plutôt ridicule j'y crois pas du tout
après en plus qui est malheureux c'est
qu'elle a dépensé autant de pognon et ça
n'a pas marché quoi mais c'est ça
surtout parce qu'au final elle a divorcé
elle a divorcé moins d'un an après
s'être marié donc tout cet argent
effectivement dépensé pour pour pas
grand chose parce que
son mari de l'époque l'a trompé avec la
femme de son cousin
comme quoi la
bougiement
explique qu'on lui a volé les vidéos
elle nie le fait qu'elle est
volontairement vous le nuire à Carla et
que le blogueur dit lui que c'est Carla
qui a rompu le contrat qui avait été
signé voilà et en plus
donc là il va se passer quoi maintenant
ok pour l'instant il y a une enquête qui
est en cours elle a à nouveau déposé
plainte parce que quand elle était venue
sur le plateau elle avait dit qu'elle je
peux plus
elle était venue sur le plateau il y a 2
ans elle avait dit qu'elle avait qu'elle
avait déposé plainte elle était avec son
avocat il me semble elle avait retiré sa
plainte entre temps par rapport à ce
contrat qu'elle a voulu honorer et là
suite à ces hommes qui sont qui sont qui
sont venus dans son appartement mais
elle a décidé à nouveau de déposer
plainte donc c'est c'est avéré ces
histoires de d'hommes dans son
appartement
Gilles oui il y a 8 hommes qui sont
venus après reste à savoir si c'est lié
à cette affaire le lien n'est pas encore
établi après ça plein de c'est pour
chantage abus de faiblesse extorsion
faux usage de faux voilà
[Rires]
et donc il y a eu de la sorcellerie
c'est sûr oui
il est possible
vous avez
vu maintenant
par une société de sécurité voilà
ce que vous la connaissez vous Carla ou
pas personnellement non
[Applaudissements]